One of the sections in the book you talk about,
um,
I believe the person's name was lunchbox Lunchbucket lunch bucket once you got
that right.
You know,
since we're talking about work environments and there's that certain level of
camaraderie and you actually talk about the seal teams in here where you just
have this,
it's like a non,
and I've talked about this before in the seal teams,
it's nonstop,
hyper verbal abuse,
aggression around the clock,
24 hours a day.
You're in a seal platoon.
Like that's the,
that's life.
Any,
any mistake that you make,
any,
any display of weakness is going to be past the part.
Oh,
it's going to be ripped apart.
And then if you get all irritated about that,
it's even worse.
The nicknames,
you talked about lunch bucket,
your nickname was howdy,
howdy doody and them be shortened to howdy.
Which one was which you felt pretty good about it's better.
Yeah,
because you went from howdy duty,
which is kind why I was so howdy,
which is Kinda cool,
right?
Western guy and whatever.
But,
but the nicknames that,
that,
that are in the seal teams,
like I can't with good conscience repeat them because they're just,
they're just horrible,
horrible names.
But there's a comradery around that.
And there's also the way,
as I was reading what you had written about,
these guys were working on a railroad railroad crew.
Yeah.
There is a test.
It's a test.
It's a test to see where you're at.
It's retro of can we,
can you,
can you tolerate a little bit of irritation?
If the answer to that is no,
it's like,
well maybe we don't want you around then.
Cause somebody irritating things are likely to come down the pipe.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's not just,
um,
to me,
to me it proves if you've got someone that can take it right.
It's not just that they can take some random joking insults like they can,
they can take it.
They can take it.
Yeah.
That's what you're testing for.
It's like,
can you take it lunch bucket couldn't write because people would laugh at as
lunch bucket and he'd get all upset.
It's like,
well you have a stupid lunch pocket.
you know your mom packed at,
how about,
did you laugh at yourself?
Yeah,
my mom packed this.
I know.
It's kind of stupid.
That would be the end of it.
He would it just have to say that,
but I didn't want to hurt her feelings.
It's like,
oh okay.
You know,
fine,
you got your stupid Lunchbucket.
But no,
he couldn't handle that,
you know?
So yeah,
it was,
it was horrible.
Had comical to watch at the same time because the level of,
and people have written me about that and they said,
oh,
you know,
poor Lunchbucket.
It's like,
cause they're all compassionate I think.
No,
no,
not poor lunch bucket.
It's like clue the hail in buddy you had your chance.
You know,
that was a desirable job,
that rail crew job in the summer because it was high paying,
you know?
And they weren't easy to come by those jobs.
And so the fact that he got hired onto that crew was a real opportunity for him.
You could make a pile of money in the summer at working on the rail crew and all
you had to do was take some ribbing with good grace,
not suck up to the management too badly and not have other people do your job.
That was all,
that was all you had to do,
but he couldn't do that.
And so he got run off and it was like,
grow the hell up buddy.
You know these guys win a hundred people are teasing you.
Then probably they're not wrong
when you are getting teased like that as well.
Well when you,
when you,
when you stop reacting,
it's no longer fun.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Who gives you an opportunity to tease back?
It's like this,
you can show your wit.
And one of the things that working class guys in particular,
which is one of the things I really loved about working class jobs is there,
they're always looking for some humor.
So it's like if person a is teasing person B,
that's kind of comical.
But if person B comes back with a good zen back,
it's like,
that's even better.
You know?
So I think that's a lot of how those jobs are rented.
Tolerable,
right?
It's,
they're,
they're hard dirty jobs,
right?
Dishwasher's a good example.
That's not dangerous.
Although cooking is,
Jeez,
you know,
you gotta Watch your step.
I got burned a lot when I was cooking.
Um,
but what makes those jobs not only tolerable,
but even desirable,
is that you can develop a tremendous amount of camaraderie around them.
I've never really experienced that at a professional level job that just doesn't
happen the same way.
And it's really,
if there's a real loss in that.
So it's,
it's,
it's fun to be part of a team that's doing,
you know,
grubby hands on things and,
and having a ridiculously entertaining,
vicious,
cruel and evil time while you're doing it.
That's very entertaining.
The,
this new kid's book I wrote,
so the kid mark,
he's getting made fun of by this.
He's a different kind of bullies,
like a mental bullying that,
that verbally abuses people.
And he gets called plate face by this character and to eventually gets in
trouble for throwing something at the kid because he's calling him plate face
play there.
But eventually the way he befriends the kid is by heat.
They have to do a self portrait class.
And he draws a picture of himself looking like a plate and he shows up again.
The kid laughs and all of a sudden their buddies.
And it's like that's what you do.
You take away that you take away the joy of,
of being so heated and irritated by people that are making fun of you and you
just kill it.
And Jujitsu in some sense.
Well,
I had an experience with that about three years ago.
I'd put my videos up online and people kept saying that I sounded like Kermit.
And I thought,
well,
one person said it and I thought,
whatever.
But then like five people said it and I thought,
oh my God,
like this Kermit thing.
So then I went and listened to Kermit and I thought,
oh no.
It's like,
it's like,
really?
I really sound like Kermit,
you know?
And so then,
well then I started to play with it a little bit.
You know,
I used the puppet and when I,
when I went to speak to university students and I made frog jokes and then I
made a v I made a couple of videos that sort of featured me as a frog.
And I mean,
it's crazy,
right?
It's ridiculous.
But,
but that's,
but,
but the teasing never got mean because of that,
you know?
And the same thing's happened online to a larger degree.
As people keep making memes of me like,
and there's,
I don't know,
there's lots of them.
There's way too many to even keep track of.
And I was watching that happen and I thought,
okay,
this is a good thing because there's humor and wherever there's humor,
that's a good thing and they're making fun of me.
But it's gentle,
you know,
most of it was pokey,
like,
well you sound like this damn puppet.
What do you think of that?
It's like,
well,
if I had to pick someone to sound like probably wouldn't be a puppet,
but for that to be a puppet Kermit's not a bad one could be a lot worse.
And I could be Miss Peggy.
And I couldn't be in that,
you know,
so thank God that didn't happen.
But the memes have never got vicious because,
you know,
I'll post them if they're funny and satirical and then they won't get vicious
because they don't have to.
It's like,
can we poke fun at you?
yeah,
please do.
And the more the better really,
because that'll also help keep my feet on the ground and keep me awake.
And plus it's funny.
And like one of the things about life is that a sense of humor,
that's a good thing to,
to arm yourself with because sometimes you just don't have anything other than
that.